I think it's really important that we
learn the lessons of covid and that's
why the inquiry was established and we
want to make sure that whatever lessons
there are to be learned are learned and
we do that in a spirit of transparency
and Candor the government has cooperated
with inquiry tens of thousands of
documents have been handed over and with
regard to the specific question at the
moment the government's carefully
considering its position but it's
confident in the approach that it's
taken are you prepared to get into a
legal battle with a public inquiry some
senior legal figures think you'll lose
that fight again not a comment on the
speculation but we are carefully
considering next steps and the
government is confident in its position
are you saying that it should be up to
ministers to decide what documents are
looked at by the inquiry not the
independent judge in charge of it again
governments handed over tens and tens of
thousands of documents in a spirit of
Candor and transparency because it is
important that we learn the lessons of
covid with regard to the particular
question at the moment we're carefully
considering next steps but the
government is confident in its position
so you might not hand over that material
that they're asking for there again as I
said government is considering next
steps carefully but has been confident
in its position and has handed over tens
of thousands of documents of the
documents that they've asked tens of
thousands of documents today in a spirit
of Candor and transparity because it's
important that we learn the lessons from
covid and again carefully considering
next steps
all right well lived Westminster and our
political correspondent Tamara Cohen
tomorrow let's begin with what they want
to hand it over and why we've had a new
twist in this route about what the
government is handing over to the covid
inquiry we had had a deadline of 4 P.M
today for the government to comply with
a request to hand over Boris Johnson's
whatsapps covering a period of two years
from 2020 to 2022 the height of the
covid crisis and also some hand-written
notes that he had been taken 24
handwritten notebooks during this period
the covert inquiry set up by the
government has quite wide legal powers
to demand a material and Lady Hallett
who chairs that inquiry said it was
relevant if the government didn't want
to hand it over and the cabinet office
had said some of it was irrelevant then
they would have to take legal action it
would all end up in court now what we've
seen in the last few moments is the
covid inquiry have extended that
deadline from 4 pm today to 4 P.M
Thursday but also said they've been told
by the cabinet office this is Boris
Johnson
um be in in the U.S being caught up with
by our journalist James Matthews what
they've what they've now said is that
the cabinet office don't actually have
any of this stuff they don't have Boris
Johnson's whatsapps or his Diaries so
that certainly raises a few questions
because a couple of weeks ago when they
were arguing to the inquiry that they
shouldn't have to disclose it all they
just said in there that there might some
of it might not be relevant some of it
might concern other subjects and uh lady
Hallett the chair of the inquiry gave
that quite short shrift and said that
she should be able to look through it so
they don't have it I understand Boris
Johnson's team don't believe they've
actually been asked in writing for any
of it although they say that he is
willing to disclose information to the
covid inquiry and but it's up to the
cabinet office in what form that happens
now many legal figures don't expect the
government would have much chance of
getting out of disclosing these
materials we spoke to the labor peer and
former Lord Chancellor Lord Faulkner and
this is what he told us this morning
and I don't think the government have
got a leg to stand on there seemed to me
to be a number of issues here first of
all the chair who's a very distinguished
ex-judge is saying I decide what's
relevant not you to the government and
that's obviously right then the
government is saying but hold on some of
this stuff is got nothing to do with
covid at all what happens if ministers
are exchanging WhatsApp messages either
about their personal life or about some
completely different issue say Ukraine
to which Barnes halletta said well one
of the things I'm investigating and
you've asked me the government to
investigate this is how you took
decisions you there's a big issue she
says as to whether or not the Prime
Minister was sufficiently focused on
kovid throughout the period he was
making decisions so I want to see what
else was going on
so that's the case for lady Hallett seen
this material we now have some
apparently missing WhatsApp messages and
handwritten Diaries from Boris Johnson
during The crucial period and another
two days to find out if the government
has made much effort to get hold of them
and whether they intend to hand them
over to the covered inquiry we are
awaiting a response from the cabinet
office to that latest development from
the inquiry